okay guys usually for movie reviews I
yeah but get the green screen setup and
do all that but honestly I just came
back from Batman V Superman I do not
have the energy I'm exhausted I feel
like this movie just beat me up Batman V
Superman dawn of Justice here's the
spoiler free version there are good even
great parts and pieces to this movie
however I cannot right now think of
another major release that I have seen
that is this poorly assembled and put
together
that's your spoiler free version because
at this point I'm just gonna rant and
there spoilers will fly now what I say
this thing is poorly assembled very
often in this film a scene will end and
then the next scene will start and it's
not immediately apparent what it is or
why and then you won't find out until
about halfway into the new scene
what is going on and why we're watching
it and you can get away with that a
couple of times this movie does that a
lot I lost count of how many times i sat
there going what the hell is going on
and it doesn't help that so many
complete threads of this thing just
there's no reason for it to be there
they are they found nothing to do with
Lois at all her entire thing with the
bullet goes nowhere okay that leads her
to Lex Luthor but she doesn't do
anything with that she doesn't tell
Superman much of anything I mean Lex's
tracking her and engaging her anyway so
she didn't need to know about Lex that
entire thread stupid pointless drop it
another thing I feel like we missed a
movie there was a movie missing in this
series you know why because what I
thought was happening I think what
everybody thought was gonna happen what
the central conflict for Batman against
Superman was going to be was that it was
gonna be coming off the Battle of
Metropolis Batman saw this destruction
saw it firsthand and look that opening
was wonderful it really established why
Batman's gotta have issues with Superman
because he sees it on the ground level
the destruction that is rocked by his
very presence and then we jump 18 months
ahead and Batman
not even doing anything about supermanny
tracking this white Portuguese nonsense
and what's more even the Senate hearings
have nothing to do with Metropolis they
have to manufacture this new thing in
forever the desert thing is where he
rescues Louis from that is now an
international incident what happened in
the 18 months that me it that meant the
world more or less forgave him for
metropolis and erected a statue in his
honor
because that also was clearly the period
in which his relationship with Louis
developed because we come in and
obviously they've been dating for a
while but we never saw them build this
relationship
Superman's down this place of really
heavy self-doubt but we've never really
seen him be in a place where that has
that he meeting because he had only
barely become Superman in the previous
movie now he's all doubting himself but
where was the stretch where he was just
going about and being hero we get one
montage of it which is a decent montage
but again comes so late in the movie
that it doesn't matter he's already
doing all this self doubt stuff look and
a lot of people who sent this already
most of the good stuff in this movie is
Batman not just bad athletes performance
which is great but the best action scene
is him going that warehouse to rescue
Martha Kent and he's also the character
who I understand the most I understand
his motivations the best I understand
what makes him tick I don't understand
the Superman I'm not saying that in a
they deviated from the classics of man
way I mean I don't get him I have never
gotten to know him in the way that this
thing needs to get me to understand him
and care about him so that his death at
the end has any meaning whatsoever not
only do I have no idea who this Superman
is I have no clue who this Lex Luthor is
why does he hate Superman I have no idea
I don't know if it's general paranoia if
it is jealousy he makes a railing thing
against God he's apparently got all
these daddy issues and knowledge adding
to anything that's going anywhere he's
got this completely out of left field
behind Jim's monologue finger he's like
you play worse things are coming or
whatever which seems to imply that he
knows about Darkseid did he know about
that before is that just because he
linked up with the Kryptonian ship I'll
come back to that thing in a second but
regardless of what he learned at that
makes the whole idea of killing Superman
seem just really dumb and make no sense
because you'd think you would want
Superman on your side if something worse
is coming and maybe I could have bought
that he would want some man dead anyway
if I really understood what his
motivation for wanting him dead in the
first place was that I really don't now
coming back to that ship what is
Kryptonian technology seriously if the
people who crewed the ship are dead just
next person who walks in you I work for
you now I'll do whatever you say
what the hell no wonder the Kryptonians
couldn't think to evacuate their own
planet when it was gonna blow up the
shoehorning in of the other Justice
League members like literally we are we
are on our way to the titular battle but
let's pause the story and do basically
three trailers for the next bunch of
films in this series and look I'm
obviously getting myself really worked
up about this again there are things
that are good I think the opening is
wonderful I think most of the Batman
stuff is really really good although I
have to question what was Batman's
tactic for taking out Superman he hits
him with the Kryptonite gas and then
beats on him up for a while why wouldn't
he just hit him with the spear
immediately I mean maybe I could buy it
the first time like you just want to see
how long the Kryptonite lasts but if he
was always gonna spare him the whole
time anyway why not just spear him and
get it done and he's got the spear
planted in the floor how did he know he
was gonna get Superman down to the floor
with that thing tactician my but this is
a horrible plan so even Batman who's the
best thing in this movie he does not
come away untainted now he's not the
only good thing in this movie Wonder
Woman is good I'm not gonna say she's
great because I don't feel we get enough
of her the parts of her that we get I
like what we get is not enough for me to
go woah but I will say I am intrigued to
see her solo movie I'm intrigued to see
the Batman solo movie I'm actually not
uninterested in this world I'm actually
very interested to even excited to see
all the various solo movies that
come out of this so I'm okay spending
more time in this world so I mean that's
my positive take away there are enough
things that work that I'm not abandoning
this cinematic universe I am still
interested or even eager to see a lot of
what's gonna come next I was not a big
fan of Man of Steel I didn't hate it as
much as some other people but I
understood what it was doing and I think
that in a large part the thing with Man
of Steel it came down to a matter of
personal opinion like whether or not
this was the Superman you wanted
basically so far as I can tell half the
people said yes
half the people said no this one I don't
even think it's a matter of opinion I
know people are gonna draw lines in the
sand along those lines but seriously
it's just a really badly assembled film
the pacing is wonky as heck scene
transitions our first [ __ ] so much stuff
either never makes sense or by the time
it starts making sense it's been going
on so long that you're just frustrated
with it anyways this thing is just a
mess that it's the best word that I can
use and there are ingredients and there
are bits and pieces in the mess that are
good but that's still a mess so Batman V
Superman dawn of Justice did you see it
has it dampen your enthusiasm for future
DC films has it bolstered your
enthusiasm for future DC films for me it
actually kind of did that as much as I
disliked this specific movie I'll stick
around I think there is a lot of
potential in this world I am actually
now oddly hopeful despite really not
enjoying this film so there you go
that's my thoughts share yours down in
the comments let's talk about it please
feel free to like subscribe follow me on
Twitter at council of geeks check out
the council of geeks podcast which is
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned